[Música]
la comisión económica para América
Latina y el Caribe advirtió que más de
200 millones de habitantes de la región
vivirán en situación de pobreza para
finales de este año de ellos al menos 82
millones estarán bajo el umbral de
pobreza extrema las alarmantes cifras se
producen en medio de la tesa aceleración
económica y la alta inflación en el
territorio latinoamericano
la presidenta de Honduras y humara
Castro declaró la emergencia nacional en
materia de seguridad para lo que
denominó una guerra contra la extorsión
la mandataria destacó que ese delito ha
dejado centenares de muertos y negocios
en la ruina a medida incluye la
militarización de fronteras y posibles
estados de excepción
en el día 34 de paro en la ciudad
boliviana de Santa Cruz los líderes de
la protesta aceptaron que el censo
poblacional que determina el reparto de
fondos a cada región se realice en 2024
esto por cuestiones técnicas no obstante
los manifestaron los manifestantes
continuarán con la huelga Hasta que el
congreso declaren ley la realización del
censo en ese año ampliamos desde La Paz
en Francia 24 estamos de vuelta con las
noticias que marcan la jornadas soy
Valentina Torres Sánchez y es un gusto
acompañarlos la comisión económica para
América Latina y el Caribe advirtió que
el 32,1% de la población total de la
región que equivale a 200 millones de
personas vivirá en situación de pobreza
para finales de 2022 de acuerdo con el
organismo unas 82 millones de personas
además quedarán bajo el umbral de pobres
extrema los responsables del informe
destacan que la desaceleración económica
y la débil recuperación del empleo tras
la pandemia sumadas a la inflación en
alza no sólo profundizan la crisis sino
que la prolongarán se enfrenta una
crisis social prolongada y urge
abordarla eh eh en particular lo que
llamamos una crisis silenciosa en
educación para evitar el riesgo muy real
muy real de una generación perdida
Entonces tenemos a esta cascada de shows
externos que incluye y que ha producido
una desaceleración del crecimiento
económico desgraciadamente esta era una
desaceleración que ya venía desde el año
y que fue impactada mucho más
negativamente por la pandemia los
confinamientos en Honduras el gobierno
de la presidenta Xiomara Castro declaró
el estado de emergencia nacional en
materia de seguridad para lo que
calificó como una guerra contra la
extorsión entre las medidas que anunció
la mandatario está en la militarización
de fronteras posibles estados de
excepción e incluso controles bancarios
según la jefa de estado son iniciativas
que permitirán combatir el crimen la
extorsión el narcotráfico y desarticular
las organizaciones criminales hasta
identificar a los responsables
para fortalecer esta estrategia de
recuperación inmediata de los
territorios sin ley
en los barrios
en las colonias
en las aldeas en los municipios y en los
departamentos
declaro emergencia nacional en materia
de seguridad e instruyó a la Policía
Nacional los presidentes de México y de
Ecuador Andrés Manuel López Obrador y
Guillermo lasso respectivamente se
reunieron en la capital mexicana en un
encuentro que calificaron de productivo
pero que no permitió el cierre de un
esperado acuerdo comercial los
mandatarios señalaron que el pacto Aún
se está definiendo ese tratado comercial
es clave para que Ecuador pueda ingresar
como miembro de pleno derecho a la
alianza del Pacífico que actualmente
integran México Colombia Perú y chile
en Bolivia en el día 34 de huelga en la
ciudad de Santa Cruz los manifestantes
aceptaron que el censo de población se
realice en 2024 esto debido a motivos
técnicos no obstante exigieron que la
realización de esa medición poblacional
quede estipulada en una ley ya la cámara
debate la iniciativa pero falta que pase
al senado merivaca corresponsal de
France 24 en La Paz nos dio más detalles
Qué tal Buenas noches bueno durante esta
jornada luego de que los líderes de la
protesta de Santa Cruz aceptaran que el
censo de población y viviendas se
realiza en el año 2024 como venía
pidiendo el presidente Luis Arce la
comisión de Constitución de la cámara de
diputados se ha dado la tarea de
concertar un único proyecto de ley para
llevarlo al pleno de la cámara de
diputados este proyecto de ley va a
establecer dos cosas uno que el reparto
de recursos económicos con base en la
nueva realidad demográfica de Bolivia se
realice a partir de septiembre del año
2024 y que la redistribución de escaños
parlamentarios también con los nuevos
datos censales se produzca antes de las
elecciones generales del año 2025 tal
como piden los opositores y los líderes
de la protesta de Santa Cruz sin embargo
la gran incógnita es si es que se van a
lograr o no los votos necesarios para
aprobar este proyecto de ley Pues existe
una persona en Bolivia que está en
contra de este proyecto y es el ex
presidente Evo Morales quien tiene una
bancada todavía fuerte en la cámara de
diputados y en la cámara de senadores y
él y sus diputados y senadores han dicho
que van a votar en contra de este
proyecto de ley no quieren que se haga
una norma para el censo porque
consideran que eso le restaría autoridad
al presidente Luis Arce por eso todavía
no se sabe si esta ley va a llegar a
buen término en ambas cámaras
se cumplen seis años desde la firma del
acuerdo de paz entre el estado
colombiano y la extinta guerrilla de las
Farc en los actos de conmemoración
participaron integrantes del partido
FARC y madres de víctimas asesinadas
entre otros involucrados en el conflicto
que pidieron que la paz No se olvide y
que los acuerdos se implementen el
secretario general de la ONU Antonio
Gutiérrez aseguró de estar muy alentado
por el compromiso del actual gobierno
colombiano de redoblar esfuerzos en la
aplicación del acuerdo
en Perú camioneros y agricultores
mantienen al menos 14 bloqueos en
diferentes rutas en protesta por el alza
de los combustibles y las casas de
fertilizantes en ese país de acuerdo con
los reportes oficiales la mayoría de los
bloqueos son sostenidos en la zona
andina en el centro y el sur del país y
se cumplen ya tres días desde el cierre
de las vías principales lo que ha
comenzado a generar inconvenientes en el
comercio y el turismo las regiones de
tacna Arequipa cusco puno ayacucho
ancash y piura son más afectadas por
estos bloqueos el Gobierno ya tiene ya
los puntos Como por ejemplo el tema del
combustible el tema de la sutran el tema
de bueno de la rebaja de los peajes el
tema del Puerto Seco de los carros
extranjeros al ingreso al Perú y tema
Bueno del tema del combustible de
contrabando una escritora que acusó al
ex presidente Donald Trump de violación
presentó una demanda mejorada en su
contra en Nueva York luego de que
entrara en vigencia una nueva ley que
permite a las víctimas de violencia
sexual demandar por ataques que
ocurrieron hace décadas y Jim Carrey
acusa a Trump de agresión por haberla
violado y manoseado a la fuerza hace
casi 30 años en esta nueva demanda Carol
Busca medidas compensatorias y punitivas
por daños psicológico por dolor
sufrimiento pérdida de dignidad y daño a
su reputación
y cambiamos de tema porque este viernes
se juega a la sexta jornada del mundial
de fútbol de Qatar 2022 los ojos de
América Latina están puestos en el
segundo encuentro de Ecuador que tras su
Victoria frente a Qatar en el partido
inaugural ahora se enfrenta al
seleccionado de Países Bajos Juan
pupiales enviado especial de Franz 24 al
torneo nos da los detalles de la jornada
se abre la segunda fecha de la fase de
grupos de este mundial de Qatar 2022 y
como protagonismo latinoamericano
Ecuador se mide este viernes contra
Países Bajos ambos sobre los países que
ganaron que comenzaron con Victoria en
el grupo a en la tri todo pasa por saber
cómo se encuentra la rodilla de su
goleador y estrella en el Valencia
rodilla izquierda parece que finalmente
estará en condiciones para jugar fue el
que marcó los dos goles en esa Victoria
inicial contra
Qatar los Ecuatorianos saben que una
victoria contra los Países Bajos los
pondría prácticamente en octavos de
final con los neerlandeses de pie
estaría disponible para disputar algunos
minutos También tenemos otros dos
partidos por el grupo B juega Inglaterra
que aplastó a Irán por seis a dos en su
Debut lo hace contra Estados Unidos que
no pasó del empate contra gales en su
Debut con los ingleses finalmente Harry
kane estará en condiciones para jugar
para eso también que el defensa
Skywalker Podría tener algunos minutos y
la duda sigue siendo James Madison ahora
en el otro partido de este grupo el
grupo B será la gales de buscará su
primer triunfo ahora contra Irán en esta
copa mundo de Qatar 2022 que entra en
una nueva instancia
este 25 de noviembre se lleva a cabo el
llamado Black Friday o viernes negro en
numerosos países del Mundo una fecha
marcada por importantes descuentos en
productos de Cara a la temporada
navideña expertos han señalado que se
trata de una jornada que este año está
marcada Por la alta inflación que se
registra en muchas naciones no obstante
se espera una participación masiva tanto
de este viernes como el lunes en el
llamado Cyber monday en el que
originalmente las mejores ofertas se
encontraban en línea
es todo por el momento en France 24 pero
quédense con nosotros que volvemos en
breve